after last week's huge reveal westworld
is back and my brand continues to melt
into mush i'm not gonna waste any of
your time we're gonna get into some of
the show's biggest theories and
unanswered questions and be sure to
stick around to the end of the video
because i've sleuthed out some really
interesting things from the trailers
that might hint at where the show is
headed episode 5 has a really
interesting title zhuangzi named after
ancient chinese text which expresses the
theme of freedom from the human world
christina is currently trapped in this
quote-unquote human world and over the
course of this episode we'll begin to
free herself from it we can hear william
talk about there being beauty to this
world a grand design which echoes the
same thing said about the original
westworld in fact new york has become a
mirror image of westworld in the sense
that the hosts now come to it with the
humans being slaves stuck in loops
william meets a man and woman for dinner
where a philosophical conversation takes
place about the nature of control how
can you be sure you have control and
you're not just programmed it goes back
to this idea of free will versus
determinism are we really making our own
choices or has everything been
predetermined just like the loops our
hosts partaken this guy believes so much
that he's in control over his life that
william pulls the rug out from under him
showing him that he has no control at
all only the illusion of it the same
thing will happen to christina who
realizes this illusion of control is but
a tool to keep her under hale's control
so are these two humans or hosts well we
know william can order them around both
seem to be brainwashed into their own
scripts and william calls them quote a
significant investment of time and
effort i'll leave it up for you to
decide william is interrupted by
clementine notifying him that a park
guest has developed an appetite that has
become unsustainable it's kind of ironic
because in season 1 william had a
similar insatiable appetite taking out
dozens and dozens of hosts in his quest
to discover the center of the maze a
trail of bodies leads william to hope
both literally and figuratively this is
the start of his own journey where he'll
question his purpose in life hope was
sent on a mission to find an outlier a
human who has for reasons unknown to
hail deviated from their loop hope was
successful in taking out her target that
homeless man christina has seen in
previous episodes however her
interaction with him has caused an
infection of sorts over the course of
three days she slowly went mad
ultimately killing herself and she's not
the only one we'll later find out there
are currently 38 dead hosts all
triggered by contact with these outliers
we learned that hope was scheduled for a
procedure next week to transcend we
aren't exactly sure what this means
however we see this guy here undergoing
this process hale describes it as quote
giving up one's human nature and it
seems to involve giving up one's body
maybe it means they've been uploaded to
some sort of virtual world like the
sublime instead of living in the real
one when we later see christina visit
this back room at olympiad we see two
maps one christina calls the city and
the other the game maybe transcending
means being uploaded to one of these
maybe there are two new yorks a virtual
one and a real one christina's job after
all is writing for a game speaking of
christina she wakes up in the same type
of shot from previous episodes as we'll
find out later teddy tells her she's
close to deviating from her loop which
may get her flagged by hail as an
outlier she still has that creepy tower
painting and she'll later tell maya
something teddy said that sometimes the
things most real are just stories
christina believes her world to be real
but over the course of the episode we'll
find out she is simply writing the
stories of those around her in this shot
we can see the olympiad building and to
the right the same structure where we
last left caleb christina busies herself
with work starting a new narrative about
a country girl living with her rancher
father a nod to delores living with her
father on the ranch like dolores
christina wakes up every morning with
the feeling that there is something
wrong with the world she's interrupted
by her boss emmett he seems to have a
close eye on her a few episodes ago he
was even tracking her but as she
explains her new narrative teddy calls
christina who somehow knows her boss is
breathing down her neck he's wanting to
meet her i totally missed this last
episode but inside the light fixtures
are those sound transmitters which relay
instructions to the humans the blood on
this guy's fingers suggests hail has
been practicing with these humans for a
very long time it's a nod to the early
days of westworld in which the humans
would teach the hosts how to dance so
it's kind of weird what's going on here
are the humans not perfected is this a
flashback to earlier days at the park
the piano plays lou reads perfect day
which also happens to be the song
featured in the first season 4 trailer
charlotte equates herself to god and
this god is bored bonus points for this
weird human chair she makes reference to
a god coming down to the mortal world
disguising himself as a swan which is a
reference to the greek myth of leta and
the swan in which zeus disguised himself
as a swan and r-worded leta it's a
pretty brutal metaphor for what
charlotte is doing to humanity hale does
not like this place it was originally
intended to be a stop gap where hosts
can visit humans but the hosts can't get
enough after all they were designed
after humans encoded with their
sensibilities william and hale take this
long bridge which connects the park to
the tower outside you can see these two
red riot robots which were featured in
season three hale informs william of
this virus and we noticed this white
flower something hope may have taken
from the homeless man she was sent to
dispose of hail has given the host the
ability to choose and she's frustrated
the hosts haven't decided to transcend
like she wants she could have forced all
the hosts to do this but won't stating
that that's what the humans would have
done an elevator takes hale and william
to the overwatch where a map shows us
how different hosts were sent to target
this outlier hope being one of them when
a human deviates from their loop it's
called a breach this is similar to
westworld and how human delos employees
would be brought in to take out
defective hosts hope broke the rules and
instead of immediately taking out the
outlier she interacted with him this
caused some sort of infection william
will later break the rules himself
interacting with another outlier on top
of a building if william is like the
others who got infected will he too
become crazy and eventually kill himself
we already see the beginnings of this
when he confronts the real william and
questions his purpose i'm not sure where
this bloody hand came from it looks as
though his hand is fine after recovering
from jay's attack but who knows i still
think there's a chance host william will
either set real william free or trade
places with him that could make for some
really cool drama later on hale will dig
her nails into her scarred arm she kept
the scars to remind her of what humanity
did to her and her family this outlier
problem is really getting on her nerves
and to top it off there's a new outlier
that needs to be caught and the rebels
are on their way she tells william that
he can't hesitate as soon as he finds
her kill her bonus points if you notice
that when hale removes the map it
briefly turns into an image of the maze
jay and stubbs arrive in new york by
capturing one of charlotte's drones
they've managed to track down one of
these outliers so it's a race against
time who can reach this outlier first
jay says that charlotte has the humans
in the park on prescribed loops that
keep them busy and stops them from
questioning their own reality i like
this cheeky shot of the statue of
liberty a symbol of freedom overlooking
a new york where no one is free
christina meets with teddy who
challenges her notion of reality we
learned that it was indeed teddy who
beat up peter and at first christina
thinks she's just traded one stalker for
another he tells her the first step in
understanding is realizing this world is
a lie teddy shows her how she has the
power to rewrite people's loops going on
to say in this world
[Music]
you're a god charlotte also called
herself a god in this episode so just
who exactly is christina she's someone
who definitely has a connection with
dolores after all she keeps wanting to
write a narrative about a lonely country
girl she also has the ability to change
other people's narratives it was my
interpretation that her co-workers who
we see here at work also writing
narratives are merely part of
christina's fake reality an illusion if
you will as we'll find out later it
seems christina has written everyone's
narratives i can't help but see the
correlation between her and maeve from
season one maeve snapped out of her loop
and had to pretend in order to get to
the bottom of who she really is she like
christina develops the power to control
others but christina is trapped in
hale's world hale keeps tabs on her and
it's almost as if hale needs christina
for some reason that's all we really
know at this point then the question
remains who is teddy it could be dolores
herself he refers to himself as an old
friend and teddy feels they've known
each other for lifetimes it could also
be the resurrected maeve acting through
him we know she can control all sorts of
ai and maybe by creating some sort of
copy of teddy that she could control it
would help in breaking christina's
illusion of the world that being said
teddy warns her to keep sticking to her
loop as to not raise suspicion jay and
the gang are attacked by will's
mind-controlled humans basically
confirming that it was him last episode
who ordered the park patrons in the
1920s world to go after caleb and maeve
will gets to the outlier first but
instead of immediately shooting her the
two interact something he's not supposed
to do it raises the question about
whether or not he'll be infected jay
ends up shooting william and bringing
the outlier to safety during an
extremely awkward coffee date it seems
as though hale is trying to interrogate
christina she asks about this mystery
man she's been seeing but before she can
answer christina causes two people to
crash into one another causing a
commotion christina heads into work and
searches for charlotte hale which comes
up with no results she then searches
dolores abernathy which is flagged as an
illegal request you can even see this
quote authorized personnel have been
notified that's gotta be concerning for
next episode emmett surprises her and
questions why she is here he'll go on to
use the line have you ever questioned
the nature of your reality which is a
question that came up multiple times in
season one have you ever questioned the
nature of your reality funny enough the
real william will tell host william
maybe it's time he questions his emmett
goes on to tell christina that hale is
already suspicious of her christina is
able to rewrite emmett's narrative
basically controlling him and he says do
you know what would happen if she knew
you'd bridge the world garden we don't
know much about this walled garden other
than it's some sort of system and that
it's everywhere it gives me the matrix
vibes with emmett leaving and suddenly
this door appearing out of nowhere it
suggests christina is in some sort of
virtual reality perhaps the very game
she told her date in episode 1 that she
writes for the episode ends with
christina telling teddy that he was
right she can now see the tower in the
distance which she couldn't before she
asks who built this world and who did
this to her which teddy says she did but
why would she want to put herself
through this unless of course teddy
isn't referring to christina directly
but a copy of her the one inside
charlotte hale that exited westworld at
the end of season 2. now up next we have
our spoiler section where we take a look
at the trailers to see where the rest of
the season might be headed correct me if
i'm wrong but i don't think we've seen
this specific shot of stubs in new york
the last we saw of him he was on a boat
headed out of the park does this mean he
heads back in bernard and c head into
the ruins of what i believe to be the
1920s park he's already in the general
area and we saw him have visions of this
park while in the sublime i'm wondering
where maeve is dolores or christina in
water really don't know what's going on
here here's caleb pursued by a drone
host one which will see him attack he's
wearing the same outfit that we saw him
in at the end of episode 4. william
shoots this guy it's a little too
difficult to make out if it's lawrence
or not but he does have an automatic
weapon on him my guess is that this is
somewhere in the real world as you can
make out this road divider in the
background
a 3d printed body and in the background
you can make out two chairs across from
one another just like humans would use
when running their diagnostics on the
hosts bernard not looking too good
remember that in all versions of the
future he said he dies not sure who this
is with either sand or ash in their
hands this is likely dolores christina
with the reflection of the abernathy
ranch in her eyes william uncovers this
tear at the hoover dam which looks
almost identical to the one which led to
the sublime in season two if host
william has switched places with real
william this could have some really
interesting consequences take a look at
this image of hale at the transcending
room there are drone hosts to her left
but look at what she's wearing the
earrings the hair the black top and
strap around her shoulders looks
identical to this shot at the hoover dam
she seems to be running from someone
dressed all in a black and we just saw
william approach the dam in black could
he be the one hunting her she has this
bag with her but i can't confirm if it's
the same one she left westworld with
that contained the pearls here's caleb
escaping some sort of inferno it almost
looks like he's opening a sewer grate
but this doesn't really look like a
street to me stubs is here at this
ransacked drugstore one which we'll
later see clementine at could this take
place in new york after all that's the
place we last saw clementine we also get
this brief shot of potentially caleb
fighting her frankie with a drone host
in what appears to be new york and maeve
finally confronting hale now i didn't
notice this before but it looks as
though hale is holding some sort of bell
could it be for mind control i guess
we'll just have to wait and find out
that's it for this video i want to hear
your thoughts and theories about the
show in the comments and be sure to like
and subscribe for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember